today is Constitution day so what's your
favorite part of the Constitution I'm
not sure but it's actually about yeah
get to do whatever you ought to do I
don't know I have no idea
lots of people had no idea but some knew
and many had favorite parts the ability
to amend it that was key
it allowed Americans to get rid of the
bad parts the Thirteenth Amendment
outlawed slavery the 21st and an alcohol
prohibition other important parts are
the right of the people to bear arms a
guarantee of trial by jury and lots of
people mentioned the First Amendment
free speech freedom of speech even
though it can be abused I'm a firm
believer in saying what I wanted to say
and I would hate for somebody to
restrict me I asked a bunch of freedom
loving people you have a favorite part
of the Constitution they're the First
Amendment Jim Caruso runs a craft beer
brewery why the First Amendment if you
don't have the ability to express what
you truly own your thoughts and ideas
you don't have any of the above
libertarian party chair Nix our walk
says his favorite part is the whole Bill
of Rights the rights of the individual
the right to free speech the right to
keep and bear arms the limitations on
the powers of government congressman
Thomas Massie says his favorite part is
the ninth amendment it says just because
we have listed some of your rights here
in the bill of rights and in the
Constitution that's not an exhaustive
list it says that all of the rights are
yours
congressman Justin Amash says his
favorite part is the equal protection
clause you can't pass laws that don't
apply equally to everyone Senator Mike
Lee chose the 10th amendment which gives
most government power to the states or
the people states do stupid things -
sure they do but the difference is with
a state you can turn around a lot faster
Charles Kirk who heads a student group
that fights against big government also
pick the 10th amendment because I think
it shows the humility of the founders
where they said we didn't get it all
right here what amazing humility for the
founders to put that in it's a
remarkable document I hate the archaic
whay parts of it are written but heck
it's still mostly working 230 years
later the reason we should celebrate
today Constitution Day
you